hello everyone my name is joey john and
it's
really my great pleasure to speak here
at simon's
institute uh today i'm going to tell you
about our work on a continuous local
search approach for hybrid
solving and this is a joint work with
anatosis qualities
and shamanish vestava and motivating
so when we are talking about step
solving what are we
really referring to and as in most cases
we mean saying half solving of course
cnf is the most prevalent
and successful format in set community
but
there are also other very important and
useful
nonsense boolean constraints which are
much less studied in this community
in graph theory there are a lot of uh
examples
um for instance for vertex covering it's
more convenient to
represent this problem by either
cardinality constraints or
pseudo boolean constraints another
example
is the hypergraph 2 coloring where not
all equal constraints
is the most natural representation
while in cryptography axor constraints
play
important rules for composing protocols
like sha-1
and i'm sure that you can list other
applications to
demonstrate the importance of nonsense
boolean constraints
so what have people done for handling
nonsense of constraints
there are two main lines of research the
first one is encoding
in tokens have been discussed in
previous workshops
but here i want to make the list some
limitations of encodings
first is about size so here is the
histogram about the blow up of number of
variables and clauses if we just want to
encode a cardinality constraint with 250
variables
so you can see the blow up here and it
is no doubt bringing
a heavy burden to the server and the
slowdown down
besides the size encodings can vary a
lot
by other aspects like arc consistency
and the solution density
so uh usually different servers prefer
different encodings
and the takeaway message here is that
just because
including is found for type of
constraint doesn't mean
it is solver friendly
well the second aspect first handling
nonsense of constraint is to use
extensions of cdcl
based set servers there are a bunch of
tools developed in this area but we want
to make
the point here that they need to design
algorithms for each specific type
of constraints while a uniform way for
handling different types of constraints
is still
lacking so both of those lines of
research kind of rely
on city sale site servers
with city cell servers relies highly on
the property
of seeing that format so we are thinking
about
can we use a more general approach
namely local search
so local search engine research is
usually the objective function is
defined
by the number of constraints of formula
satisfied
by some assignments there are many many
classical rhythms in this area gsat is
one of them
where you start from a random initial
point and
you just keep flipping the variables
with the best value
until you reach a solution
local search gives us interesting
theoretical results and
in practice it was shown to be effective
on
red heart random and crafted instances
as well as metasite instances
so we want to ask can we use discrete
level search
for announcing of solving
let's see what happens so remember that
discrete research also relies on some
properties of
cnf which is an unsatisfied clause can
always be fixed by flipping just
one variable but
does this property also hold if we want
to solve non's enough constraints
probably not let's see the following
example
here we have a cardinal constraint with
four variables and
suppose we start from this all false
assignment
now it is unsatisfied and we will try to
flip
one variable let's say the first one to
make this
new x now there are two things to note
notice the first one is that the
constraint is still on set
the second thing is that and the even
worse thing is that
if we just use the way we define the
discrete
objective function in cnf solving we
will
see no change to the discrete
objective although we think that we are
making some progress because we are
closer to satisfying this cardinality
constraint
so that indicates some problems with
using discrete objective for nouns
enough solving
the first one is that discrete local
search is limited to flip a single bit
pre-iteration
second discrete objective function fails
to capture
the progress towards satisfying a
nonsense of
constraint so maybe staying in discrete
domain is not enough
and here is what we are planning to
solve those problems
for as for discrete objective fails to
capture progress
we we plan to design a continuous
fitness function
to measure the progress since district
load search is limited to flip a single
bit per iteration
we are thinking of just search inside of
the box
and do continuously research so that we
are kind of flipping
more than one bit simultaneously maybe
we'll just flip each bit
slightly but we can manipulate a subset
of bits instead of just one
so i think it's a good point to wrap up
a little bit
and show you some really work on
continuous
approaches for set solving which is not
a new thing because people have
developed both convex realizations and
non-complex polynomial
representations for step solving
so for the left part we do have lp
relaxation and
as the periodization those relaxations
gives us
good theoretical guarantees but they
usually fail to give high quality
solutions in practice
while on the right the cmf formula is
usually
transformed into a sum of product
polynomial
but in the previous literature they
failed to give sufficient theoretical
analysis about this transformation
and also note that this transform only
applies on cnf formats while we want to
solve
non-synthetic constraints as well
one point that both of those directions
are missing
is the success of gradient-based
techniques
achieved in machine learning and we
believe that those advantages and new
techniques
are not fully leveraged in the stat
community
so we want to explore the potential of
continuous local search
so here i will just show you the overall
workflow of our
framework and the goal is to
design an effective framework that
handles different types of constraints
uniformly giving
so our input is hybrid boolean formula
and we can do some kind of transform
which i will describe later
to generate a multilinear polynomial
then
we will be able to do continuous
optimization
based on some gradient approaches
we may end up converting to global
maximum local maximum or center point
but no matter which point we convert to
we can always discriticize it to check
if it is a solution or not if not we
just go back and
do random restart
so in the rest of this talk i will be
decomposing this framework
into different pieces and show you how
each component actually works
the first and the most important part of
our framework
is how we define this continuous fitness
function
let's go for it remember that the
discrete objective function is just the
number of constraints
the number of satisfied constraints
as we discussed before this function is
kind of
too discrete so that it fails to capture
some small progress
towards satisfying nonsense constraints
can we define a real value fitness
function for the boolean formula
usually the one of the ways people do it
is to define
a real value function by probability
space
here is how we do it we want to define a
fitness
real value function for all the real
vector
which are constrained in the boolean
bonds from -1 to 1.
so we can define a probability space
based on the real vector a
the probability space will be applied on
all the boolean
vectors
so here is how we do it the these
coordinates
of the boolean vector will be
independent from each other
and the value of x i will be only
decided
will be only uh related with the value
of a
i so roughly speaking if a i is positive
then x i has a greater chance of being
one if sampled from the probability of
space s a
and if a is negative then vice versa
here is an example a is a 2d
real vector and here is a table
probability table showing
how what's the probability of each
variable taking some specific value
and we can sample a boolean vector from
this table
so after we get this probability space
one of the
way that we can define our real vector
real
value function is to use a probability
that the formula is true under this
probability space
right so this looks good
but unfortunately this probability is
sharp pre-complete to evaluate because
it just it reduces to the model counting
problem
but we can step back and compute
something easier
which is the expectation of the original
objective function under this
probability space
so what happens if we choose this
representation
now the capital f the fitness function
measures how many constraints are
satisfied
in expectation under the probability
space
and we can not try to maximize this
fitness function with respect to a which
is constrained in the boolean box
where a is a real vector
so uh generally speaking this real
value fitness function gives us a way to
to measure
how good a real vector is while we're
doing search
the next next question to ask is how to
evaluate
this fitness function a naive approach
takes at
exponential time of course but it turns
out
that this fitness function can be
evaluated in polynomial time
by the so-called watch fourier
expansions which i will describe in the
next
slide the word for expansion is
main theoretical technique we are using
in our framework
while ryan has written a remarkable
textbook
on this topic i will just give a brief
introduction
it is basically a technique which
transforms boolean functions
to multilinear polynomials
for example the formula if the formula
is x and y
then i will claim that this polynomial
is the first expansion the reason is if
you
evaluate this polynomial on all the four
possible
discrete assignments you will see that
the boolean function and
the polynomial agree with each other
and this phenomena is general in the
sense that every single boolean
constraint
has a unique representation a
multi-linear polynomial
that agree with the constraint on all
the boolean assignments
but what happens on the real vectors
the polynomial itself does not prevent
us from evaluating it on real vectors
if we do so we may generate a surface in
high dimensional space with it which is
useful
in our framework so how does it help us
to evaluate
our objective function
recall that we define our real domain
fitness function
by the expectation so by the linearity
of expectation we can expand
this representation to the sum of
probability
that each constraint is true under the
space that we defined by a the real
vector
one of the contribution we made is that
this probability can be computed
exactly by evaluating the fourier
expansion
if we just use the same real vector a on
both
sides of the equation
so now we are able to rewrite our
fitness function by the sum of fourier
expansions
of each constraint here is
an example now phi has two different
constraints and we can transform them
both into
their corresponding fourier polynomials
and add them up to get our polynomial
representation
of fitness function so we will be able
to evaluate
it so here finish our first part
and the second part is about versatility
so since we are motivated by handling
non-cf constraints
and so we will see how we do it
recall that our fitness function is
defined
can be rewritten as the sum of four
expansions so if we have
a new type of constraint and we know
they can
close form for your expansions of that
constraint
then we'll do it but for what type of
constraint
can we do it fortunately many types of
interesting constraints
have their closed form for expansions
from outsourced to
cardinal constraints to not oracle
constraints
and including cnf in
cnf classes we further proved that
for all symmetric constraints we have
their own their
closed form for expansions
so here comes to the last part and i
believe that
in this part a lot of questions can be
raised for example
can we say anything about global maximum
saddle points or local maximum
or how fast is the convergence or after
we discriticize
the converging points what is the
quality
of this assignment so let's answer these
questions regarding convergence and
grounding
the first thing i want to tell you here
is about
global and local maxima
another contribution we made is to prove
global maxima or all preserved in real
box
so if we what do i mean by that let's
first consider the scenario in
discrete research in this regular search
file is satisfiable if and only if the
maximum
of the discrete objective value is that
is the number of constraints
this is easy to see and what we have
proven
is that this theorem also holds
in the continuous space so here i need
to replace
the discrete objective value to the our
fitness function
which is real value and
i need now the maximum operator is
applied on all the possible
real vectors in the box constraint
and the maximum of the fitness function
is still
the number of constraints so that means
the fitness function is well behaved
inside of the tube and it won't exist it
exits
the number of constraints we cannot end
up finding some global maximum inside of
the tube
so it's not always realistic to convert
to a global maximum
so we have to consider the case where we
go to a local maxima
can we say anything about local maxima
to answer this question we need to study
the geometry of multilinear polynomials
so multilinear polynomials are globally
non-convex and non-concave which is not
useful for
optimization but luckily
multi-linear polynomials are always
convex along some directions while
concave on some other directions
so as a result neither of this ball
shaped local minimum
nor this local maximum can appear
on the surface of multilinear
polynomials
the only place which may trap our search
is such a saddle shape
but sellership is not the worst thing in
search because
we have a great chance of escaping from
it
uh formally speaking if we do not
apply our box constraint on every point
there will always
be a direction where we can increase the
value
the polynomial value but if if we
uh impose our bot's constraint then this
escaping direction maybe towards the
boundary so we must
encounter local maxima along the
boundary or in other words the local
maxima should be
on the boundary so this
kind of reveals of the discrete nature
of our framework despite of its
continuous appearance
so we formalized our intuition by
proving that all look maxima
are almost discrete assignments
so what do i mean by almost discrete
let's say an example
now phi is x or y logically speaking if
one of x or y
takes value true then no matter what
value the other variable tapes
phi should always be true this also
holds in the
polynomial world so now f
is the corresponding polynomial and we
can see
on the plot that on the blue point at
the blue point we can
we can move the blue points along the
axis without changing the polynomial
value
so that means we can round the
fractional coordinates
which does not matter at some specific
points
so those points are so called almost
discrete
because if we just reach this point i
think we should stop
search and maybe do random restart
because
it's third continuous searching is not
useful at all what we proved is that you
can start from a fractional point
at the beginning but if you are able to
convert to a local maximum
then you will finally end up with the
following point
where most of the coordinates are
discrete which means they are either
plus one or minus one
while this a small set of variables are
fractional
but we don't care about those variables
because changing
the values of those variables does not
affect the value of the fitness function
in other words for a local maximum
rounding preserves
the objective value
so this somehow gives us some guarantees
about the solution quality of
local maxima because randy now
does not harm which is different from
the case in
lp both lp and the sdp relaxation
where running pn cost loss to the
objective in other words local maxima
are meaningful
and they do provide good quality
solutions for some more relaxed
problem like mad set
i also want to answer the question about
how fast can we converge
first of all i want to emphasize that
our framework does not limit
anything about which optimizer you
should use so you can use any optimizer
as long as
as long as it solves the constrained
uh a polynomial optimization problem
but here we will focus on the productive
gradient and sense approach
for those who are not familiar with it
it is just
general gradient ascent but projecting
the outlier back to the box region
by finding the nearest point so
sometimes
when it happens the projected gradient
will be different
than the ordinal gradient
a point is called a critical point if
the projected gradient
at that point is absolutely small and
our
one of our theorem is that if
if our framework uses projected gradient
descent
then it will always converge to a
critical point
in polynomial steps
but what does a trickle point look like
in most real-life cases quicker points
are just local maxima
which will prove that they have good
quality
but theoretically speaking a critical
point can still
be a saddle point so you can see a gap
here on one hand we proved that
local maxima are meaningful but on the
other hand
we can only prove that we will convert
to a
critical point the reason this step
exists is because of set of points set
of points
it's other point is a trigger point that
is not a local
optima like this one
although in real life cases that the
point of real exists
really exists but in
some crafted instances they can appear
for example those are the gradient plots
for
outsourced constraints you can see that
just at the middle of the boolean box
saddle point
exists where the gradient vanishes
but practically we observed that
our framework seldom converts to such
standard points
so an open question we raise here is to
prove that our framework does not
convert to
this other point with high probability
so here here i think the framework has
been
introduced so in this slide i want to
tell you some improvements that we made
on this framework
in our newest paper where we use a new
representation of boolean constraints
called binary decision diagram
we use bdd to handle coefficient bounded
pseudo boolean constraints
since the efficiency of computing the
gradient is very
important for continuous load research
we accelerated the gradient mutation by
bdd
significantly also we do
we are aware of the fact that inside
community
converging to a global maximum is much
more important than just having a
local maximum so we also use adaptive
constrained weighting
borrowed from discrete research to get
better global convergence
so if you are interested in any topics
of those
i encourage you to refer to our newest
paper
so it's time to show you some
experimental results
the highlight of our framework is its
performance on
some small size playing mat set
computation
where our approach gives the best
solution for most cases
compared with other match set
servers while we also tested our tool
on some real hybrid boolean formulas
containing xor and the pseudo boolean
constraints
well we observe that our server is
better than discrete load research
servers but
it cannot match the performance of
state-of-the-art cd sales server or sudo
boolean
servers yet of course the city of the
art stores are well engineered
and usually the continuous operation is
much more expensive than
the it's discrete counterpart
so we believe that those results already
show some
great potential of this framework
uh on large industrial instances the
cost for differentiation
is really too expensive so we need to
work on that
all right in summary we're motivated by
handling constraints that beyond cnf
and we want to explore the potential of
continuous methods in second method
solving
our framework exhibits nice theoretical
results as well as interesting open
questions as a continuous
based approach in practice
our server can act as a complement to
existing servers
since the framework can be decomposed
into parts
it should be banned it should benefit
from the
improvement from each area for example
tractable structures of boolean
constraints and the techniques
in continuous optimization
as for challenges and the future
directions
first of all the full gradient is really
expensive on industrial benchmarks so we
want to compute imprecise gradient
second we also want to learn from
discrete
search to combine that with our
framework
to design a solver with better
performance
third since the neural symbolic approach
is really
popular now our solver exhibits good
potential of being as a
layer of neural network as a
differential optimizer
also we want to verify the real value
fitness function to see if we can
find any insights of different
logical formulas we also want to connect
our algorithm with some welding matrix
message passing algorithms like survey
republicans
and we will dig more into this with that
i would like to conclude my talk thanks
for listening and i'm happy to take
questions
thank you g way for a very nice talk
uh looks like jacob has a question i
think
yes please
uh you mean in absolutely
do i get it right that this is an
incomplete method that is yes
solutions it is so complete
yeah and did so did you considering
like combining it with some complete
method that could do
like the unsatisfiability part and maybe
you would do the search part
or this is on the list of things to do
or it doesn't work or
yeah so if you mean by proving
unsatisfiability by
other completely different methods yes
of course we can do that but if you mean
prove proving unsatisfiability by
algebraic approach
like groups and basis of
like other approaches then we we think
people have done that before but they
failed to scale well
so we haven't done that yet
but there is jacob there is interesting
insight for example how you look at
resolution from this algebraic
perspective so it turns out the
resolution here translates to
to linear operations
right ua yes exactly
so there is a potential to do to add for
example kind of inferencing
yes so there is a potential but uh it's
hard to see
how they can be as efficient as
resolution currently
other questions or comments
yeah i would have a question so like uh
would it not also make sense to have an
imprecise
encoding into bdd so similar like what
the
hooker and other colleagues from cmu are
doing for optimization like
dropping those sort of high degree
monomials you have in your four year
because you're only saying here on this
conclusion slight uh sort of imprecise
gradient but you could also do an
imprecise
uh imprint size encoding exactly so
i think using an
exact representation of the polynomials
corresponds to
cut off some nodes of the corresponding
bdd
so they are basically the same it's it's
just a spectrum
method with keeping the compo the major
component
okay um i have
asked a quick question yes um
so in the first part you
for the basis uh depending so you define
the expected
expectation depending on that variable a
and then in the second part as i
understand it you optimize over that a
now that expectation looked i have
not did not fully grasp it but it looked
natural to me um
but are there alternatives to that
or do you think that's it so that's the
natural choice
to to that basic definition from the
first part
well so so our
the question is a question about whether
we can do better than
defining a fitness function based on
expectation can we use
alternative definitions yes
yes so do you have any comments margin
no maybe even change the probability
distribution
yes yes those are all promising
directions but
we did tried several different
representations
but the expectation is the most suitable
one because it is multi-linear
which means it is somehow smooth
and uh yeah so it's a balance between
easy computable is it computable and uh
and the precise
so last question i'll read the questions
from the from embry
which is the did we consider to doing
parallel cells starting from multiple
points
and then using perhaps the power of gpus
yes that is definitely a promising
direction because our
framework exhibits a good potential of
that
so yeah i believe that
the the performance of our of our
framework depends on
how many trials you have you're doing
and
if we can manage to parallelize it
on gpus it will be very nice
but since the search contains some some
logical steps
it's not clear how to do it at this
moment
okay well thank you thank you guy for
the presentation thanks thanks for all
the questions